ontario said another record for
hospitalizations today the area
hospitals are having a difficult time
100 people in icus in the province in
the daily case count of covet
hospitalizations highest level yet at
884. one group is missing
covet patients who are discharged from
acute care beds but too sick to go home
they are sent to a different type of
facility a rehabilitation hospital
here they are fighting to recover
in the invisible hospitals of the
pandemic
good morning everyone starting with miss
romero room 341 her respiration is 22
and she was suctioned three times during
the night
the third floor unit at toronto grace
health center was born out of covid
created for patients who need to be on
ventilators long term
both coveid and non-covet patients stay
here to take the strain off acute care
hospitals
[Music]
it is 5 am and paddy romero is about to
come off the ventilator
[Music]
patty is transitioning to what's called
a trach mask
breathing on her own with oxygen flowing
into an opening in her neck
sleeping well
good morning good morning the last time
paddy tried to come off the ventilator
her lungs were too weak
the team here is hopeful
this time will be different
only three months ago paddy's life was
vibrant
[Music]
as a kidney transplant recipient patty
knew she was at high risk of severe
covid
[Music]
and she was waiting for her first dose
of the vaccine
when she tested positive for covid the
decline was rapid
her lungs filled with fluid
doctors sedated her put her on a
ventilator and warned her kids she may
not make it i'm just gonna give you some
suctioning okay now to help her breathe
respiratory therapists clear her airway
four to five times a day
give me a big cup okay
good job
if the fluid isn't removed paddy could
develop pneumonia for a second time
for a unit like this to even be possible
toronto grace had to be agile
it repurposed the existing floor and
added 175 new staff across the hospital
including physicians with icu expertise
we'll do another 20 hours or maybe 22.
dr margaret herridge is the unit's
clinical director so we've just built
this really in the last 12 to 15 months
it didn't exist at all so we built it
from nothing here they help patients
relearn what most of us take for granted
go on three one two three today paddy
will try walking again good
you're doing well okay
her body is so deconditioned each step
is exhausting but we're right beside you
not going anywhere okay well done okay
you took a few steps there
what's wrong with you
that's amazing
it's amazing
there's a joy
here's a joy
[Music]
the bickel center at toronto rehab also
created an entire unit in the middle of
the pandemic
60 new transitional care beds a hundred
new staff
hello how are you doing today dr mark
bailey is the medical director of
toronto rehab our capacity has been
running over a hundred percent which is
really unheard of for a long time so
this extra burden of the covid patients
has affected us to be admitted to a
rehabilitation hospital a patient has to
be physically able to participate in
therapy
when sean balcaran arrived he couldn't
even move his arms or legs
every rehab hospital he applied to
turned him down
except bickle let me know
when i'm in pain after eight weeks here
shawn can move his limbs again
but his hands barely function i can't
bear the pain no more occupational
therapist susan curry is trying a
utensil cuff how does that feel hoping
it will help shawn regain some
independence
the nerves in sean's hands are so
severely damaged
they could take two to three years to
heal
i'm dead now that's good though you did
like 10 bites
the mental fight is equally hard 2
3
shawn's mind knows what he can do no no
we're going but his body needs more time
i think we need to take a break here no
we're almost there physiotherapist yi
fan tsu knows that if sean overexerts
himself he may not be able to do therapy
tomorrow we're going to take a break
first so we can reset listen to me
please okay
at 53 sean wasn't concerned about covid
he wasn't eligible for a vaccine yet but
he wasn't planning on getting one i
thought it was a joke at first it was
just like a big flu that was going
around we weren't wearing masks we're
going anywhere we wanted within days of
testing positive he was airlifted to a
hospital in ottawa sedated and put on a
ventilator his wife nori was warned his
brain may be severely damaged they said
he may be on ventilator for life or you
decide what you want to do
the only thing i can really tell you is
i prayed
so
yeah
okay
so now you make me
want to cry it was hard
that's why i'm here every day
had you ever heard of west park before
no didn't know existed
a hundred years ago west park healthcare
center used to be a tuberculosis
sanitarium
today it's opened 23 new beds as a
response to covid applying its expertise
in respiratory care we are going to test
your oxygen chris smith came here with a
primary goal
getting off the oxygen tank ready two
one if his oxygen level stays above 88
percent while walking for ten minutes he
passes the test
but at only two minutes it starts to
plummet you're gonna have to terminate
okay he has oxygen dropped way below
unfortunately it went down to 83
simply being able to walk is monumental
man
this was chris three months ago while at
north york general hospital
his body ravaged after being in acute
care for weeks
the day he was rushed there in an
ambulance was the same day he got a text
that he could get his first dose of the
vaccine
take a nice deep breath while i listen
to your chest okay okay chris's chest
finally sounds clear but kovid has
reduced his right lung capacity by a
third
it will be an uphill climb to get home
breathing on his own
i can see her she's all ready
back at toronto grace patty is hitting
another milestone deep breaths okay her
tracheostomy tube is being removed she's
freaking out though so we need to
do this quick
it is time to take this trach out
don't be nervous
it's a big victory right we had little
victories this one's a big one okay
you might feel a little bit of tickle of
when i'm doing the
ties around here
but it shouldn't hurt at
good breath all and pop it out
good
looks good just gonna put a band-aid on
now can you try and say hi to me hi hi
picture your voice changes yes
relief
yeah because it's one step closer to
home right get you out of here
while patty is moving toward
independence
she is still reliant on a feeding tube
for nutrition
and water is still a no-no not yet soon
speech language pathologist shireen
abbas introduces real food gradually
thank you
knowing if it enters paddy's lungs it
could cause an infection banana pudding
this week is the first time patty has
tasted food in three months
this is better than sex trust me
[Music]
in a rehabilitation hospital the days of
struggle are plenty
oh gosh
so the triumphs are something to savor
[Music]
i am more
hi
no one tells you about the moments
you'll miss if you get severe coveted
in only three weeks patty's daughter
karina is due with her second child
and patty is desperate to be there
but the time it takes to heal from covid
is as unpredictable as the virus itself
in rehabilitation hospitals they count
in weeks and months
not days
[Music]
the work here is unseen to most
this isn't the front line
nor is it capturing headlines
helping keep paddy going her son eric
while his mother was in the icu he could
only see her through a glass door
and when the family was told she may not
make it they would gather beneath her
window and pray her
room was on the second level
i would like um
like have dinner or lunch
in the parking lot yeah
just wanted to be there
as much as i could
while patty has made it through the
worst her body is still weak good good
good good she can't fully lift her arm
her muscles need strengthening feeling
good oh lord have mercy and her left
foot has extensive nerve damage and she
can't flex it by putting this in
hopefully her toes won't drag along the
floor to help physiotherapist rory
magner tries an ankle brace in paddy's
shoe she's also attempting to walk
without supplemental oxygen for the
first time focus the breathing
into the nose out through the mouth
good and stop
oxygen level came back up to 90 very
quickly there so that's great
you feeling tired oh my goodness
that sounds like yes it feels like i run
a marathon
it does
the pain in sean's shoulders is so
intense he's being transported to
another site at toronto rehab for some
relief hi there doc how are you
physiatrist dr jordan ferraig is hoping
a cortisone injection will ease sean's
pain and increase range of motion
but simply getting undressed is a
challenge
wait can you hold on one second
just any movement is excruciating yes
shawn's doctors believe he has what's
called frozen shoulder from being
immobilized in hospital so long i'm just
going to move it uh gently okay
yeah so right about there yes that
really hurts eh
sorry sean
dr ferraig will inject the cortisone
directly into the shoulder using
ultrasound for guidance that's our
needle coming from the right side of the
screen
doing so well
that's it we're done
[Music]
it's been a month good morning sean
and dr alexandra rendley is here to see
if the cortisone shot worked so show me
what you're doing now well
it's there so this is at least 75 better
than before the injection
breathe
so the range has improved dramatically
sean's shoulders may be healing
but his hands are taking much longer so
you're going to squeeze these and see if
you can get it on the side of the ball
as a mechanic of 34 years his livelihood
depends on them
oh too tight why don't we practice just
picking up and putting into the bowl
okay
but so what does that mean for your job
i don't know i can't be off that long
like mentally financially no
sean's savings are gone
and he stopped receiving government
support three months ago i've applied
for
all sorts of things
and
been denied
how much money do you have left
boring from people
yeah so covet is making you go broke i
am broke
the cost of being sick is felt in many
currencies it is a lot on my head to
comprehend the challenge that i'm in
right now chris too has had to rely on
others for financial support a lot of
people were sending money in though in
time he will be able to work again as an
i.t project manager
coveted mercifully spared his hands
gonna open this up now but not
his feet
while chris was in the icu he needed an
ecmo machine it pumped his blood outside
his body to receive oxygen
but it meant blood flow didn't reach his
toes
doctors feared he might lose four of
them
nail is about to come off slowly they
are beginning to heal i'll just wait up
a little bit nurse petty landing rinses
them with saline and swabs them with
antiseptic this is better than it helps
with the drying of the scar sitting for
too long or walking too far can be
intensely painful ok we're done but
chris will need his feet to hold out
long enough for him to pass his last
test remember walk at your own
comfortable pace walking ten minutes
without supplemental oxygen two
one go last time he barely made it past
two minutes
right now he's at 94 percent it's the
best we've had okay don't jinx it
today the recovery is evident we've
achieved it how does it feel
great chris no longer requires
additional oxygen wow
and in four days hello hello
he will go home smile
close your eyes you feel buzzing down
here yes much like chris
patty is also recovering from the impact
of being in the icu
touch your nose
touch my finger her hands trembling from
tendinitis caused by being immobile so
long what they do in the icu you need
you need that to save your life and then
you come to a place here so we deal with
the after effects of that but patty
isn't looking back
have you heard anything have i heard
anything about them
about sorry about this discharge
they're waiting to see how you do with
stairs so in theory uh maybe in the next
week or two even oh thank you jesus
you guys heard that
we heard it we heard it
sean balcaran has been in hospitals for
243 days
his hands have improved yeah that's
that's as far as it'll go right now but
that's a hundred times better than it
not moving his body 65 pounds lighter
i've become a better person to realize
kovit's no joke
yeah
rehab hasn't healed his wounds
completely are we all ready yes but it
has gotten him to a place he could at
least go home
here we go we're going home
[Applause]
patients who spent time in a rehab
hospital
sometimes talk about the gifts from
kovid
how a disease that nearly killed them
i got this gave them something in return
thank you so much again perspective
patience
a second chance
516 bed one romero patricia palino 650
milligrams was given independently and
also was given insulin independently uh
he's going to be discharged home at noon
it is paddy's last day at toronto grace
you ready
[Music]
thank you thank you thank
you so proud of
you rehabilitation centers are the
hospitals most people don't know about
until they need them
be careful without you guys
i won't be able to walk and
and do everything that i'm doing right
now and i thank you so much from the
bottom of my heart
thank you and god bless everyone
in this one
it took a team
to reunite a family
[Applause]
and give a grandmother the embrace
she had been waiting for
me
oh my goodness